show me the one whose safety deemed such
destruction
you must reunite it with its own kind
where this you must determine
the songs of eon's past tell of battles
between mandalore the great
and an order of sorcerers called jedi
you expect me to search the galaxy and
deliver this creature to a race of enemy
sorcerers
this is the way
you know this is no place for a child
wherever i go he goes
so i've heard
this is the way
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new star wars the
mandalorian season 2 trailer video there
were a bunch of new characters that
debuted in the trailer in a bunch of new
locations that everyone had questions
about so i'm going to focus
mostly on that there's a bunch of big
easter eggs and obviously a bunch of
rumors about
other characters from the star wars
canon showing up in live action
so if you're new to the channel of
course i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get
everything
we'll do a giveaway for disney plus all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
trailer on the video so just starting
with the big stuff first number five
a lot of you saw this hooded figure in
the trailer when the armor and the
mandalorian mentioned the word enemy
sorcerers
talking about the jedi and there was a
lot of confusion over who this was
this is the mandalorian on the planet
mon cala where the mon calamari and the
quran live there's all these corn
walking around in the background we've
never been here in live action so this
is also very exciting in addition to
this new mystery character
a lot of people thought that she might
be sabine red because there's been
rumors that she's gonna show up in the
live-action series in the mandalorian
season two
some people actually thought this was
rosario dawson's ahsoka character
but some of you did guess correctly
though this is in fact
sasha banks the wwe wrestling star who
reportedly joined the mandalorian season
2 in a mystery role
zoom and enhance you can see the clear
resemblance i don't watch a ton of
wrestling so i wasn't super familiar
with the actress before all this
mandalorian stuff but she is wearing
very jedi-like robes
and in this period in galactic history
even though there aren't a lot of jedi
around there are also people who used to
be jedi jedi trainees who escaped the
purge in order 66
and there's the whole concept of the
church of the force so there are a lot
of force sensitive people running around
but the way they cut the trailer with
her in it
in the way they place her in this
timeline when they're talking about jedi
they really want to make you think that
she might be connected to whatever jedi
storyline or ahsoka storyline is
happening during the season
ahsoka is the only real jedi character
or former jedi character that we know is
showing up during season two but that
doesn't mean that she'll be the only
force sensitive person
sasha banks could also be playing a
totally new character like
ming nas fenix shand they were about
half and half during season one when it
came to doing celebrity cameos
some of them were pre-established star
wars characters from the canon and some
of them were just totally new characters
no joke mark hamill himself luke
skywalker even did the voice of the ev99
droid in the most isolated cantina when
they went to tatooine in episode five
like the one from jabba's palace
that's right this was mark hamill nobody
figured that out when the episode first
aired until jon favreau dave flony and
the star wars people did this whole
behind the scenes documentary for that
particular
episode there were a lot of rumors about
other star wars rebels characters
joining the mandalorian and showing up
in other live-action star wars disney
plush shows sabine wren ezra bridger
and probably the biggest one was grand
admiral thrawn but number four the
sabine ren rumor is actually connected
to earlier reports of an ahsoka tano
spin-off series with rosario dawson's
version of ahsoka
so just to be clear this is what rosario
dawson looks like this is a lot of
fan art that makes her look like ahsoka
in what she might
wind up looking like on the series i
think she'll look a little bit different
but i think this fan art is pretty close
but supposedly when rosario dawson
signed on to play ahsoka for the
mandalorian season 2 the contract
included a bunch of other cameos in
appearances on other live-action shows
not all them during the same time period
too like she's a little bit younger
during the time period where the obi-wan
kenobi series is going to take place so
it's totally feasible that she cameos on
that too
the reason why sabine wren is such a big
deal and relevant to the mandalorian
series is because she herself
is a mandalorian by birth she's still in
her 20s during the events of the
mandalorian series
so sasha banks is the perfect age to
play that character
and after kanan died during star wars
rebels they also revealed that sabine
was force sensitive even though she'd
been wielding the darksaber for a little
while
you don't actually have to be force
sensitive to use the dark saber anybody
can pick it up and swing it around
but rebels did imply that she herself
was actually force sensitive just not
quite as powerful as some of the other
characters like ahsoka
kanan darth maul or ezra bridger the
rumors about ezra bridger in grand
admiral thrawn showing up in live action
were actually just connected to the
ahsoka spin-off series but a lot of that
is just rumors and speculation right now
disney hasn't confirmed any of that yet
when people saw sasha banks in the
trailer though a lot of people thought
that they were hiding her hair under
that black hood just to hide the fact
that it might be purple hair because
sabine has
purple hair and that would just be a
dead giveaway for who she was playing
so it is possible but just remember that
she could be playing a random one-off
character so don't blow your stack if
she doesn't wind up being sabine wren
moncala is a new republic world so
unless she's another bounty hunter or
assassin working for mob gideon
it is implied that she'll wind up
helping the mandalorian and baby yoda
during the season
number three ahsoka herself rosario
dawson doesn't appear anywhere in the
trailer that we know of unless they
digitally edit her
out of the background there were
multiple trailers for the mandalorian
season one before
episodes came out and each one revealed
more of the characters but none of them
gave away the secret of baby yoda
so she feels like one of the biggest new
things that fans have been curious about
during season two so don't be surprised
if ahsoka does not
show up to like the last trailer right
before episodes drop
there were also a lot of you guys on the
trailer who thought that the icy planet
that they traveled to and walk around
on might be ilum because it's an icy
planet that's very important to the
history of the jedi order and has
appeared in several star wars series in
the movies
and in the video games and the scene of
them going to the icy planet in the
razor crest is edited
so that they're flying there right when
the armorer says this you must determine
after the mando asks where the jedi are
it also happens right after the scene of
them flying over tatooine
which itself is kind of a funny easter
egg for the jedi because anakin
skywalker
luke skywalker and obi-wan kenobi all
lived on tatooine
but for thousands of years ilum was the
main location the jedi trainees traveled
to
in order to obtain kyber crystals to
make their lightsabers as part of their
training
they went there a bunch during the clone
wars episodes yoda taught the younglings
all about lightsaber crystals and how
the planet itself was very strong in the
force
once you have found your crystal do not
remain
inside as daylight ends the door will
freeze over again
and you will be trapped more recently a
lot of you will also remember you
traveled there during the star wars jedi
fallen order game there's a bunch of
missions that take place there
and that's happening right after the
events of order 66
between the prequels in the original
trilogy even bigger though most of you
will remember that during the events of
the new star wars trilogy star wars the
force awakens
it's also the location of the starkiller
base
that's right they confirmed a long time
ago that the first order terraformed
ilum
turning it into the starkiller base ilum
is located in the unknown regions over
here on the map
and you have to imagine that the
mandalorian the planet mandalore is way
down here on the other side of the
galaxy
but because it's over here in the
unknown regions where the first order
was they actually started the process of
terraforming it into the starkiller base
around the time period where the
mandalorian takes place
just a few years after return of the
jedi in the battle of jakku
before all that happened though before
the events of the mandalorian series the
emperor started a full-blown
strip mining operation on ilum after the
fall of the jedi order in the rise of
the empire
right around the tail end of the prequel
era after anakin skywalker had become
darth vader and they started
construction on the first death star
so by the time of the original trilogy
movies ilum would be a hotbed of
imperial then eventually first order
activity
they completely strip mined it to create
the first and second
death star super lasers so that's why i
think it's unlikely that this icy planet
that they travel to
is ilum it could wind up being hoth if
they're really reaching for hardcore
empire strikes back easter eggs
they did legit go to tatooine during
season 1 and they're going back to
tatooine during season 2 as we see in
the trailer
so it's normal for them to be super on
the nose with their original trilogy
references
but it could also just wind up being a
random ice planet
the number one the really cool easter
egg here in this whistling bird scene
where baby yoda just says peace i'm out
of here
is that this alien bounty hunter that's
talking to the mandalorian
there are actually some people that
believe this is secretly mark hamill and
they're just modulating his voice a
little
bit so that it's not clearly
identifiable as mark hamill in another
surprise quote-unquote cameo like he did
during season one like you would never
guess
it was him unless they told you it was
him some other people think it sounds
like john fabro
but i don't think it totally sounds like
john favreau and i don't think it
totally sounds like mark hamill you guys
can let me know in the comments who do
you think
this surprise celebrity voice over cameo
is
but it's an abyssin from the original
trilogy and the prequels
they're a species that's native to abyss
where the emperor's stronghold is
located a planet incredibly strong in
the dark side of the force in the inner
core worlds
right after that whistling bird scene
where he takes this alien down with his
vibroblade that's a zabrak
they were very common during the clone
wars episodes mostly because there was
so much darth maul during the clone wars
but i also think it's another easter egg
hint about darth maul returning
on the obi-wan kenobi series that's
going to be set during the past though
and when this mandalorian series is
taking place
darth maul has already been killed by
obi-wan kenobi so darth maul himself
will never
show up during the mandalorian season 2
unless this is an easter egg
the obi-wan kenobi series is going to be
taking place around the same time
as solo a star wars story so luke
skywalker is going to be very young but
darth maul is still very much alive in
running his crime syndicate
if you watched a lot of the
documentaries about the mandalorian
season 1 you may have seen dave filoni
also say something funny about george
lucas
making him bring darth maul back to life
for the clone wars this is the clip of
him talking about that
but it's it's everything that the entire
three films of the prequels hangs on
is that one particular fight and maul
serves his purpose
and at that point died before george may
bring him back but he died and that's
showing you again how the emperor is
completely self-serving he doesn't care
he's just a tool and he's using people
that was actually part of a larger clip
where dave filoni breaks down the star
wars saga
as a whole and what the story of star
wars is really about it's completely
mind-blowing so i had a link for the
full version of that at the end of this
and in the video description
but if you spotted any other really huge
star wars easter eggs in the trailers
that i didn't mention in my videos yet
just write them below in the comments
and of course i'll do more videos as we
get more footage and get more details
about the new
characters everyone click here for that
really awesome dave filoni clip of him
talking about the meaning of star wars
and click here for my other really big
mandalorian season 2
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
this is the way